مسدا على اسرا عزل يحاول الاحتلال ترميم
جدار هيبته الذي نقبت المقاومه الفلسطينيه
بعد ايام من اقتحام كتائب القسام مستوطنات
غلاف غزه نشر جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
مقطعا لما قال انه لمسلحين فلسطينيين
قتلوا في اشتباك مع قواته لوحظ ان ترتيب
المقطع لا يتوافق مع سير الاحداث تحقيق
للجزيره حلل المقطع واعاد ترتيب احداثه
وتمكن من تحديد موقع تصويره فظهرت الصوره
الكامله كانت دبابه اسرائيليه تقوم بعمليه
تمشيط على بعد 460 مترا من احدى فتحات
العبور التي احدثتها المقاومه في الجدار
العازل وخلفها تسير قوه راجله ظهر من
خلفهم اربعه فلسطين ين يلوحون بقمصان في
علامه على الاستسلام وكانوا يسيرون بشكل
طبيعي ولم يبدو على احدهم اي اصابات جلس
الاسرى الاربعه على الارض فيما يبدو انه
استجابه لاوامر القوه الاسرائيليه التي
كانت تقطع الطريق امامهم الى قطاع غزه بعد
لحظات اصيب اثنان منهم بعد استسلامهم حيث
تمدد احدهما على جنبه مستندا الى ذراعه
اليسرى بينما تمدد الاخر على بطنه محاولا
تعديل وضعيه جسده بكل اريحيه وبدم بارد
قتل جنود الاحتلال الاسرى المستسلمين حيث
يمكن ملاحظه اثار ارتطام الرصاص بالارض
الرمليه اعاد الجنود ترتيب مسرح جريمتهم
حيث تظهر اثار سحب جثه احد الضحايا لصفها
الى جوار جثث زملائه قبل وضع سلاح عند
راسه لتصويره
بحسب المرصد الاورو متوسطي فان الاسرى
الاربعه قد يكونون مدنيين عبروا السياج
بعد انهياره وبحسب اتفاقيه جنيف فان اعدام
الاسرى بعد استسلامهم يعد جريمه حرب سواء
كانوا مدنيين او
[موسيقى]
عسكريين